Guten Tag. Mein Name ist Gündus. Ich bin auf dieser ...
Oder wo sind wir heute?
Stimmt, Krankenhaus, ja.
Ich bin in der Notaufnahme oder in der Notaufnahme,
in diesem Habe, in Ersten.
Und möchte mit Ihnen das Anamlesigespräch führen.
Ist das in Ordnung für Sie?
Ja, natürlich. Ich will ja Hilfe haben.
Natürlich sind wir für Sie da.
Aber bevor wir mit uns hierhin beginnen,
möchte ich Ihnen ein paar alte meine Fragen stellen.
Wenn Sie etwas nicht verstehen können,
oder Fragen haben, dann ist das okay.
Ja, natürlich. Was mache ich?
Darf ich Ihren Namen erfahren?
Ja, ich heiße Helene Berger.
Können Sie Ihren Vor- und Nachnamen büchten?
Ja, der Vorname ist H-E-L-E-N-E.
Helene.
Helene Berger.
Und Berger ist der Familienname, auch mit lauter E's.
B-E-R-G-E-R.
Sie sind eine Frau, ist das okay?
Ich bin eine Frau, ja, genau.
Okay.
Frau Berge, wie alt sind Sie?
Ich bin 62 Jahre alt.
Was sind Sie, Günal Geborgen?
Der 12.6.59 ist mein Geburtstag.
12.6.59.
Okay.
Bitte?
Ich bin 1,64.
1,64.
Okay.
Wie viel wiegeln Sie zur Seite?
Ja, 84 Kilo wiegeln.
Was für Beschwerden haben Sie zur Seite, Frau Berge?
Ja, also, mir geht es ein.
Ich seit einigen Wochen nicht so richtig gut.
Und ja, jetzt habe ich langsam ein bisschen Sorge bekommen,
dass da doch irgendwas dahinter steckt.
Und zwar kriege ich so schlecht Luft,
dass ich mich belaste.
Also, wenn ich im Treppenhaus die Treppe hoch gehe,
nach einer Etage fängt das schon an,
dass ich so das Gefühl habe,
dass das so in der Brust so eng wird
und, ja, dass ich gar nicht so gut Luft kriegen kann.
Und jetzt habe ich tatsächlich seit einiger Zeit
mir auf mein Bett hochgestellt,
dass ich nachts schlafe mit so ein bisschen erhöht im Kopf,
weil ich sonst überhaupt nicht zur Ruhe gekommen bin.
Ja, das ist über fünf Wochen.
Aber das wird halt irgendwie nicht besser.
Okay.
Ja, das fühlt sich, so, ja, so, dass ich, dass ich nicht genug Luft da reinbekomme.
So richtige Schmerzen eigentlich nicht.
Ist, äh,
ist, äh,
ist, aber, wenn man, wenn man so diese Angst hat
dann ähm,
dann, dann heucht man eigentlich ja mehr so da drauf.
Aber ob das jetzt schneller oder langsamer ist kann ich gar nicht sagen.
Okay.
Äh,
behofft sesi ge command having
Beschwärten
Power.
Ja, also,
halt immer dann, wenn ich mich ein bisschen anstreinge,
wenn ich, also treppen hoch hier
Einkaufstasche habe oder...
Bei jeder Belastung.
Eigentlich immer, weil Belastung, ja, ja, ja.
Oder auch neulich habe ich die Betten bezogen,
wo man dann auch so ein bisschen, bisschen die Streifen muss
und hochheben und so.
Und dann, ich finde das gleich wieder an.
Im Ruhe, aber Zeehaben keine Wischwerden.
Nein, da geht es, also da ist das nicht so ausgeprägt.
Aber zum Beispiel Nacht, da streng ich mich ja nicht an,
aber da habe ich trotzdem das Gefühl, dass es besser ist,
wenn ich den Kopf hochliegen habe.
Wenn Sie ein bisschen hoher Kollege, fühlen Sie sich besser.
Das fühle ich mich besser, ja.
Okay.
Schwellen ihr Beine oder können Sie an?
Das ist mir tatsächlich aufgefallen.
Ja, da haben Sie recht.
Seit wann haben Sie bemerkt diese Bechwerden?
Ja, wann stellt man das fest?
Irgendwann merkt man mal, dass die Schuhe nicht so gut passen
oder dass die Socken dann so einen dicken Rand hinterlassen,
dass das so eingezogen ist.
Aber das ist bestimmt schon fünf Wochen.
Gleich, so gleich seit die Treten auf.
Ja, ungefähr so zur gleichen Zeit, ja.
Okay.
Abgezählen von dieser Bechwerden sind Ihnen noch etwas affälliges aufgefallen?
Ja, so morgens habe ich so ein bisschen husten immer,
bis ich so in die Gänge komme.
Da habe ich immer das Gefühl, ich muss erstmal ordentlich abhussen.
Und ich fühle mich einfach total schlapp und müde.
Also ich merke, dass ich nicht mehr so leistungsfähig bin.
Und ja, wenn ich mich auch mehr anstrengen noch,
was ich, wenn ich dann in 2. oder 3. Stock hoch gehe,
oder auch wenn ich mich dann bücken muss, um die Schuhe auszuziehen,
dann merke ich auch, dass mir manchmal schwindelig ist.
Ist ihr husten trinken oder gibt es dabei Schleim?
Nein, das ist nur dieses Gefühl, dass ich husten muss.
Okay.
Sie fühlen sich schlapp und haben Müdigkeit.
Ja, wirklich.
Um Ihre Allgemeine zustande zu beurteilen,
möchte ich Ihnen weitere Fragen stellen.
Abgezählen von dieser Bechwerden,
füllen Sie sich allgemein gut?
Ja, also in meinem Alter, ich habe halt auch ein paar Risikofaktoren.
Also ich sag nachts schon nicht so besonders gut
und muss auch zwischendurch mal auf die Toilette gehen.
Wie oft gehen Sie zur Toilette?
Ja, einmal, bestimmt in der Nacht, manchmal auch zweimal.
Ja, und freundlich ist auch schon bekannt,
ich habe ein bisschen hohen Blutdruck
und seit drei Jahren hat mein Arzt auch festgestellt,
dass die Blutfettwerte ein bisschen erhöht sind
und da kriege ich auch Medikamente.
Medikamente nehmen Sie auch Bluthochdruck und Lipid-Kolesterinwerte?
Ja, was nehme ich denn alles ein?
Ich nehme HCT ein, 12,5, eine morgend.
Ich nehme Bisoprolol ein, dann habe ich Lysinopril
und Atovastatin und dann nehme ich noch Markumar.
Markumar?
Ja, ne halbe...
Seit wann nehmen Sie Markumar?
Das nehme ich seit sechs Monaten, ich hatte nämlich mal Vorhofflemann
und da hat man dann gesagt, soll ich lieber das Markumar nehmen,
damit dann nichts passiert.
Sie nehmen HCT Bisoprolol, Lysinopril, Atovastatin und Markumar.
Genau, richtig, ja.
Für uns haben wir nochmal sagen, in welcher Dosis und wie oft nehmen Sie ein?
Ja, also Markumar, eine halbe, die nehme ich abends ein.
Bisoprolol, fünf, nehme ich eine morgend.
HCT 12,5, nehme ich eine morgend.
Lysinopril, zehn, nehme ich auch eine morgend.
Mein Gott, ich brauche kein Frühstück mehr.
Und Atovastatin, 20, nehme ich auch eine morgend.
Also morgens habe ich eine richtig große Ration.
Ja, ja, Sie haben viele Medikamente.
Ist Ihnen übel Frau Berger?
Ja, also manchmal ist mir so ein bisschen übel,
wenn ich mich belaste, ne?
Also im Zusammenhang mit Schwindel und dann kommt so ein bisschen Übelkeit dazu,
aber also übergeben oder so muss ich nicht.
Ja, Sie haben Schwindel, können Sie nicht Schwindel,
ein bisschen beschreiben, wie fühlt sich die, wie fühlt sich der Schwindel an?
Ja, ich muss mich festhalten, damit ich nicht irgendwo gegenlaufe oder so.
Müssen Sie sich schon mal schon übergeben?
Nein, nein, so schlimm ist das nicht.
Sie gehen mehr als sonst zur Toilette,
haben Sie Probleme beim Schulgang?
Eigentlich nicht, nee.
Hat sich Ihre Gebi in Lesterzeit verändert?
Ja, ich habe tatsächlich nochmal ein bisschen zugenommen, ja.
Bin ich gar nicht glücklich darüber.
Wie ist Ihre Appetit?
Ja, meistens ist es ja eigentlich gut, ja.
Wie ist das, Gebi-Sunami?
Gevolt oder ungevolt?
Ja, natürlich ungevolt. Ich bin ja schon 84 Kilo.
Ja, vielleicht, wie essen gerne,
wie warten, ja, tsunami, ja, deswegen...
Nein, aber eigentlich versuche ich das im Griff zu halten,
aber in letzter Zeit ist es eben hoch gegangen.
Wie viel Kilogramm haben Sie schon?
Ich habe immer 81 geworden, jetzt wiege ich 84, also...
3 Kilogramm, in welcher Zeit passiert das?
Ja, vielleicht so in 3 Monaten oder so.
Schützen Sie mehr als sonst?
Es mir nicht aufgefallen.
Wurdum Sie schon mal operiert Fraberga?
Ja, tatsächlich habe ich vor 10 Jahren eine Knieprothese bekommen,
im rechten Bein.
Abgezählen, dies ist die Operation,
haben Sie noch andere bekommen?
Sonst, OP ist nicht weiter, nein.
Okay.
Sind Sie vorständig geimpft, Fraberga?
Ja, ja, ja, ich bin...
eigentlich habe einen sehr sorgfältigen Hausarzt in der Hinsicht, ja.
Haben Sie Corona-Impfungen bekommen?
Hab ich auch bekommen, ja.
Okay, das ist gut.
Was ist Ihre Allergie für Fraberga?
Ja, also einmal muss ich aufpassen mit Hausstaub.
Ich habe also so eine Hausstaubmilbenallergie,
da kriege ich Schnupfen von und muss frisch Banisen und die Nase läuft.
Muss ich immer gut alles sauber halten.
Und dann habe ich tatsächlich auch noch eine Allergie auf Amoxicillin.
Da habe ich so einen Ausschlag bekommen davon.
Vertragen Sie alle Lebensmittel gut?
Sonst Lebensmittel kann ich alle gut vertragen, ja, da habe ich keine Probleme.
Sie haben keine Unterreglichkeit, okay.
Nein, nein, nein.
Raun Sie Fraberga.
Ah, seit sechs Jahren zum Glück rauche ich nicht mehr,
aber vorher habe ich lange Zeit geraucht, zwar nie so schrecklich viel,
aber doch vom 18. Lebensjahr an habe ich eigentlich immer so eine halbe Packung am Tag geraucht,
aber jetzt seit sechs Jahren nicht mehr.
Wie lange haben Sie geraucht?
Nein, nicht ganz 40 Jahre.
Okay, trinken Sie Alkohol?
Ja, also ich trinke abends gerne mal ein Glas Bier oder auch zwei.
Ja, und wenn es im Sommer heiß ist, trinke ich auch schon mal am Nachmittag ein Glas Bier,
also zwei bis drei Gläser Bier am Tag trinke ich holen.
Als Ehre erschen möchte ich wissen, ob Sie Drogen konsumieren.
Oh nein, das mache ich nicht, nein, aus dem Alter bin ich raus.
Gibt es in Ihrer Familie wichtige Erkrankungen, Fraberga?
Na ja, mein Vater ist schon vor Jahren gestorben, der ist 80 Jahre alt geworden.
Der hatte tatsächlich eine Karzinomerkrankung, der hatte Knochenkrebs
und bei meiner Mutter, da hat man jetzt einen hohen Alter, Tumor im Unterleib festgestellt
und die wird aber behandelt und ist damit jetzt eigentlich stabil.
Wie alt ist Ihr Hamut?
Die ist 86.
Hab ich nicht.
Nein, habe ich gar nicht.
Arbeiten Sie noch, Fraberga?
Bitte was?
Was machen Sie beruflich?
Ach so, Entschuldigung, das habe ich nicht akustisch verstanden.
Ja, ich bin Frührednerin.
Ich habe als Hausmeisterin gearbeitet und das war natürlich auch ziemlich anstrengende Arbeit
und man musste immer viel sauber machen und das ist mir dann irgendwann schwergefallen,
da bin ich in Rente gegangen.
Seit wann sind Sie in der Rente?
Ja, seit zwei Jahren.
Sind Sie verheiratet?
Mein Mann ist schon gestorben, ich bin verwirkt.
Es tut mir sehr leid.
Leben Sie alleine oder?
Ja, ich bin alleine.
Gibt es jemanden um Sie kümmern?
Ja, ich habe drei Kinder, aber die sind natürlich weiter weg bzw.
Ein Sohn ist in der Pflegeeinrichtung, der hatte einen Motorradunfall,
da muss ich eher hingehen und mich um den kümmern.
Aber die Kinder würden wohl mal nach mir gucken,
aber normalerweise bin ich alleine.
Sie haben eine eine Bedeutung, das ist eine schwierige Situation.
Wie kommen Sie klar mit dieser Situation?
Ja, ich meine, er ist ja versorgt und ich tue was ich kann, um nach ihm zu schauen.
Ich besuche ihn halt regelmäßig und versuche ihn ein bisschen zu unterstützen,
aber es ist natürlich eine traurige Situation.
Ja, Sie haben das.
Okay, Frau Berger, ich habe von meiner Seite alle wichtige Fragen gestellt.
In diesem Zusammenhang möchten Sie noch etwas hier zu fügen
oder haben Sie Fragen an mich?
Ja, also eigentlich habe ich jetzt so viele Fragen beantwortet,
dass da glaube ich nichts mehr offen ist.
Was möchte ich denn gerne von Ihnen wissen?
Wie es weitergeht, was kann man denn tun dagegen?
Was ist der Hintergrund? Das wüsste ich natürlich gerne.
Ich möchte wieder mit Ihnen schüpfen, okay?
Ja, das ist okay, dann warte ich das ab.
Okay.
Jetzt kommt die obligatorische Frage, ob irgendjemand aus dem Plenum noch Fragen hat
oder irgendwie was ergänzen möchte.
Ja, ich möchte ein bisschen...
Hallo.
Wir haben es in Geschenk gesagt, aber ich denke, es sind etwas mehr Details erforderlich.
Ob ich die bieten kann? Mal gucken.
Was macht es denn Sie noch nicht?
Ja, zum Beispiel...
Wie viele Kisten benutzt man sich zum Schlafen?
Noch mal bitte.
Ich habe das Bett so ein bisschen hochgestellt.
Aber welche?
Das Oberteil. Den Oberkörper leg ich hoch.
Müsste Sie nachts wegen Atomnot aufwachen oder auf die Toilette?
Auf die Toilette gehe ich eigentlich nicht wegen Atomnot,
sondern weil ich dann merke, dass ich zur Toilette muss.
Aber vielleicht hängt das eine mit dem anderen zusammen.
Haben Sie oft Herzklopfen, Stolpern oder Rasen nach köpelischer Belastung
oder auch in Ruhe?
Ja, eigentlich habe ich das schon gesagt,
dass ich, wenn ich mich belastet habe, mein Herz spüre.
Haben Sie schon einmal das Beussein verloren?
Sie haben gesagt, es gibt Schwindel, aber...
Unmächlich bin ich nicht geworden.
Was sind Sie letzter im Krankenhaus gewesen?
Weil wann haben Sie das letzte Mal Ihren Labor-Tests für Markumar machen lassen?
Wenn ich das so genau durchkomme...
Die Pferanzielldiagnose, z.B. Lungenembolie,
die Atchärfibulation und Markumar, ein Genom und...
Ja, also ich sage mal, wie oft wird das Markumar eingestellt?
Ich denke, mein halbes Jahr ist der letzte Abbesuch her.
Ja.
Verhaupte ich jetzt mal.
Wie hoch wird der UNH Wert in der Labor-Analysis für Markumar, z.B.?
Da müssen Sie meinen Hausarzt fragen, das weiß ich nicht.
Ja, vielen Dank.
Vielen Dank.
Danke schön.
Okay.
Machen wir die Vorstellung?
Guten Tag Frau Obererstein.
Hätten Sie Zeit für mich?
Ja, natürlich.
Ich möchte Ihnen eine Patientin, die ich gerade gesehen habe, vorstellen.
Ja, wunderbar.
Frau Helena Berge ist eine Patientin, die 62 Jahre alt,
40, 60, groß und 40 Kilogramm schwer ist.
Die Patientin hat sich wegen seit fünf Wochen, 5 Jahren,
die Dismü bei uns vorgestellt.
Nach der Angabe der Patientin sind die Beschwerden
bei Belastung aufgetreten.
Und außerdem ist der Dismü von Engagefühlen,
Orthopne und bei Belastung Taki Kardi begleitet.
Und die Patientin hat sich wegen der Dismü von Engagefühlen
übergetragen.
Bekant, sei, ja. Die Patientin sei, vorstellen die Geimpfte, inklusive auf Corona. Die Patientin reagiert allergisch auf halfstab,
halfstab, mit allergie-scherenitis, amoxasilin allergie-oxen-sich mit exantem.
Beide Patientin keine Unverträglichkeit bekannt. Sie den Nikotin-Konsum habe sie vor sechs Jahren eingebaut,
halbe schachtelprotakt. Sie trinken jeden täglich zwei und drei Flaschebier, Drogenkonsum wurde fernleinnt.
In der Familienanamnese ist Erbenin vert das Igofata, sei osteosarcom, oder fernstorben.
Was machen Sie denn, was steckt denn jetzt dahinter bei der Patientin? Also erst mal was glauben Sie und was machen Sie dann für Diagnostik?
Ja, die Anamnestische Angabe, die doyten am ehesten eine Herzinsuffizienz.
Um die Diagnose zu bestätigen, muss ich zuerst die Patientin körperlich untersuchen und ich muss Brutdruck messen und Puls messen.
Und ich muss ödehme, ob die Patientin ödehme hat, beurteilen.
Und außerdem müssen wir EKG schreiben und eine Ekokardiografie durchführen.
Und außerdem eine Röntgen, eine Torax-Röntgen ist auf sinnvoll.
Ja, warum?
Wir können in der Torax-Röntgen Lungen und Herz beurteilen.
Was erwarten Sie?
Zum Beispiel Kardiomegalifönüverbeurteilen, Lungenödemaufönüverbeurteilen.
Ja, oder eine fragliche Stauung.
Und wir können auf der Ankernekrankheit auszuschließen, zum Beispiel Pynomotorax.
Ja, was gibt es denn überhaupt für Differenzialdiagnose?
Differenzialdiagnose ist eine Lungen-Emboli- und Myocard-Infakt.
Haben wir noch eine Idee?
Möglicherweise noch irgendwas?
Wenn man jetzt vom Herzen mal wechdenkt, hier ist noch erwähnt, finde ich aber nicht so wahrscheinlich, eine pulmonale Hypertonie.
Ja, pulmonale Hypertonie.
Gut, okay.
Aber das findet sich ja eigentlich jetzt, wenn man sie untersucht.
Wonach gucken Sie denn bei der körperlichen Untersuchung außer nach den Ideen beim Abtasten?
Wonach gucken Sie?
Abgesägen von den Ideen müssen wir...
Lungen ist die Stau.
Ja.
Als wenig Dau.
Ja, als wenig Dau.
Ob die Halswähnen...
Ja.
Und dann müssen wir noch gucken, ob es veränderten Klopfschall gibt, ob Leber und Milz vergrößert sind.
Ja, ja, das kann sein auch.
Und was zieht das auch ausschließen?
Ja, ja, wir müssen uns bedenken, ja.
Gut, und was für Labor werden Sie denn abnehmen?
Um die Lungenembole auszuschließen müssen wir, das sage ich mir, um die Myocard Impact auszuschließen müssen wir Kardiale Marker beachten.
Um die Allgemeine Gesundheitssustand der Patienten zu beurteilen müssen wir Leber verte, Milz verte, Kleines, Blut, Elektrolyte...
Ja, genau, das war's.
Gut. Ja, wenn sich das jetzt tatsächlich bestätigt, dass sie also eine Herzinsuffizienz hat, was würden Sie der Patientin empfehlen oder was würden Sie an Therapie machen?
Ich lasse mich mit dem Anberaten, weil ich würde gerne ein kardioloches Konzil schreiben.
Das ist eine gute Idee, ja, okay.
Aber was werden die Kardäologen denn wahrscheinlich machen?
Die theoretischen Therapie, die Entlastung der Herzinsuffizien müssen wir zuerst die theoretische Technik einsetzen.
Jetzt nimmt die ja schon eine Menge Tabletten, was würde man denn vielleicht noch machen?
Äh, wie ist das?
Wir können auch ACH und HEMA.
Genau, ja. Genau. ACHEMA und Beta-Blocker ist noch erwähnt.
Und die Frau bringt ja eigentlich jede Menge Risikofaktoren mit. Also was können wir noch machen?
Risiko, sie haben Atrial Fibrillation.
Also sie halten Hypertonus, die hat die übergewichtig.
Die ist übergewichtig.
Wie hat sie eine Blutzeitwerte?
Ja, wir empfehlen die Patienten Gewichtreduzierung und Sporttreiben.
Ja, Enduro-Lebensstil, das ist genau der Stichwort.
Und gesundheitliche Ernährung.
Ja, genau.
Gut, alles gekommen.
Ich bin komplett zufrieden.
Ich habe alles drauf.
Hier sind noch Zusatzfragen.
Ja, die Patientin fragt noch, warum habe ich denn angewicht zugenommen?
Weil ödehme.
Weil ödehme. Ja.
Weil ist ganz dain.
Weil das kann nicht gut arbeiten.
Das ist die Blut im GWB.
Und es führt zu ödehme im GWB.
Und in Schlimmstenfall im Bauraum.
Ja, deswegen hat die Patient ödehme.
Und diese 3 kg schüpricht für ödehme.
Also praktisch das zusätzlich eingelagerte Wasser wiegt so viel.
Ja, das ist der Punkt.
Ja, die Prüfer haben noch Zusatzfragen gehabt.
Die haben gefragt, was ist Pulsoxymetrie?
Pulsoxymetrie, wir können ein klein, mithilfe ein kleines Gerät,
Sauerstoff, Zettigung der Patientin bestimmen mit Finger.
Am Finger, genau.
Warum ist das ein besonders probates Mittel?
Warum rendet man das gerne an?
Ich habe nicht verstanden.
Warum wendet man die Pulsoxymetrie gerne an?
Weil wir müssen die Pulsoxymetrie einfach mithilfe von kleinen Gerät ein bisschen beurteilen.
Ja, das ist nicht invasiv.
Ja, es ist nicht invasiv. Es ist nicht wahnsinnig teuer.
Und es gibt ziemlich schnell einen Überblick, wie es den Patienten geht.
Genau, das ist der Punkt.
Dann fragen die hier noch, was ist COPD?
Und wie kann man die ausschließen?
COPD, chronische obstruktive Pulmoner, lungen Erkrankung.
Die Patientin hat auch Risikofaktor für diese Krankheit, weil sie ungefähr 40 Jahre lang gerault.
Wir können mithilfe Lung- und Funktion-Tests machen und ausschließen.
Genau, ja.
Gut.
Also, ich würde mal sagen, erschöpfend, die alle Fragen beantworten.
Die Patientin hat sich sehr wohl gefühlt.
Sie ist sehr nett behandelt worden und sehr nett befragt worden.
Und die Ärztin hat auch zu dem Fall keine weiteren Fragen.
Es sind alle Sachen erschöpfend beschrieben worden.
Also ich glaube, du kannst deiner Prüfung wirklich mit sehr viel Gelassenheit entgegensehen.
Das ist ein großer Kompliment für mich.
Ja, aber auch wenn ich von dir mal was schriftlich bekommen habe, das war immer perfekt.
Danke.
Also ich habe da überhaupt keine Sorgen.
Wo musst du hin zur Prüfung? Düsseldorf, oder?
Düsseldorf, ja.
Auch ein armes Düsseldorf.
Am 17.
Ja, ich habe schon gehört, dass da ein ganzes Nest am 17. dran ist.
Ja.
Aber du musst dir keine schlaflosen Möchte machen dafür.
Danke.
Gut, hat noch jemand von den Kollegen was zu ergänzen?
Zu unserem speziellen Fall.
Ich denke sehr gut.
Wenn das kein Kompliment ist.
Aus berufenden Munden.
Ja, ja, ja.